gut dann willkommen zu einer neuen folge
bei 4 lukas heute mit professor gab
professor für religionsphilosophie und
wir sparen uns heute die chinesische
philosophie im allgemeinen und den da es
muss schön dass sie da sind ich freue
mich sehr auf unser gespräch und genau
fangen wir doch erst mal an wie sind sie
zu chinesischer philosophie gekommen was
es so ihr bezug dazu
was waren die gründe dass sie sich mit
dem thema beschäftigt haben chinesische
philosophie ist für mich so etwas
gewesen wo ich einfach per zufall mehr
oder weniger dazu gekommen bin also für
philosophie habe ich mich immer schon
interessiert habe das auch in meiner
schulzeit schon gerne gemacht
philosophische texte gelesen und als es
dann an die studienwahl ging ziemlich an
nachzudenken was kann man denn so viel
nebenfächer machen und dachte mir warum
eigentlich nicht sinologie das ist was
neues das kenne ich nicht
das ist doch mal was irgendwie
exotisches da kann ich sachen machen ich
bin ja noch gar nicht gemacht habe und
ja so bin ich dann irgendwie ganz
schnell dazu kommen ich auch mit
chinesisch für die so viel zu
beschäftigen
ok und waren sie vielleicht auch in
china und haben da ein bisschen stehen
können oder wie er das war zeit meines
studiums schon so dass ich auch ein
auslandsaufenthalt in china gemacht habe
ich habe damals an der bayerngas
winzinger studiert das kennt man
vielleicht hier im deutschsprachigen
raum noch als tsingtau das ist die
ehemals deutsche kolonie
die außerhalb chinas bekannt geworden
ist durch das berühmte tsingtau bier
dass man so mehr oder weniger jedem
china restaurant der welt bekommen kann
ja aber da hatte ich dann auch eine
zeitlang chinesische sprache und kultur
studiert genau allgemein chinesische
philosophie da das so ein bisschen mir
für dieses interview so sehr wichtig
gewesen zu überlegen okay ich habe so
eine vorstellung von einer person die
gibt es auch gar nicht so dass eine vage
vorstellung dass eine person die macht
einmal die woche einmal die woche oder
monat ist es egal yoga macht ein
bisschen qigong beschäftigt sich 0
mit philosophie mit texten und hat dann
höre ich immer so ein satz so ist dieser
vagen vorstellung nächsten satz von
borja chinesische philosophie richtig
interessant so das ist ja sowas wie
irgendwie im moment leben so innerer
frieden so das kannst du mir darüber
erzählen so das ist so ein bisschen die
vorstellung die ich da so manchmal so
hat die ich von außen höre hab ich ein
seminar bei ihnen besucht und war dann
sozusagen davon überrascht dass das
tatsächlich überrascht habe ich habe
einfach gemerkt dass gar nicht so also
da
ich würde gerne so wie wir zu sagen die
erste frage werdet wie kann man
chinesische philosophie abgrenzen und
unterscheiden von westlicher philosophie
und was ist da so der kern eigentlich
wenn es überhaupt einen gibt ja also
zunächst mal würde ich sagen die
einfachste antwort auf diese frage was
ist eigentlich nächste philosophie das
ist philosophie in china also eigentlich
finde ich man kann chinesische
philosophie nur geografisch abgrenzen
und in gewisser weise auch sprachlich
oder kulturell also eben chinesische
philosophie ist die philosophie wie sie
im chinesischen kulturraum betrieben
wird oder in chinesischer sprache
betrieben wird das kann man nicht so
ganz klar voneinander abgrenzen
ich habe immer so ein bisschen ein
problem mit aussagen wie die chinesische
philosophie ist so und so weit es gibt
nicht die chinesische philosophie es
gibt philosophie wie sie in china
betrieben wird das ist dieselbe
philosophie sozusagen wie die die wir
hier im westen betreiben es gibt nämlich
nur die eine philosophie es gibt nicht
verschiedene philosophien sondern es
gibt die eine philosophie an der wir
alle als menschen partizipieren können
und die hat eben verschiedene
ausprägungen gebildet hier im westen
oder da in china und unsere westliche
vorstellung also die dominierende
vorstellung von chinesischer philosophie
hier bei uns in der gegenwart die ist
verzerrt finde ich also natürlich da
findet man so leute wie die die sie
beschrieben haben die sagen ja
chinesische philosophie im fluss leben
und alle widersprüche sind 1 uns etwas
das gibt es in der chinesischen
philosophie also es gibt strömungen die
solche dinge sagen es gibt strömungen
die halten das für ausgemachten
blödsinn und sagen genau das gegenteil
also die chinesische philosophie die ist
sehr vielfältig und diversifiziert
innerhalb von sich selbst und solche
aussagen wie die chinesische philosophie
ist so und so
die sind meistens totale über
generalisierungen eine zweite frage
werden nämlich gewesen so gibt es nun
auch eine spezielle östliche oder
fernöstliche denkweise dann nein
wahrscheinlich
ich würde eher sagen nein also wenn man
ehrlich ist muss man sagen es gibt nicht
das östliche denken was ist das
westliche denken ich meine schauen wir
uns nun unsere eigene philosophie an
hier in europa oder im westen insgesamt
die ist auch extrem diversifiziert was
sollten wir sagen auf die frage wie ist
das westliche denken
vergleichen wir platon mit aristoteles
mit kant vergleichen wir sie mit
nietzsche vergleichen wir sie mit
heidecker es gibt eine gigantische
vielfalt innerhalb des westlichen
denkens und man kann nicht einfach sagen
dass westliche denken es so also warum
sollte es dann beim chinesischen denken
anders sein
wir können auch nicht sagen dass
chinesische denken ist so und so aber
jetzt muss ich doch mal sagen wenn sie
mich in die ecke drängen und sagen aber
es muss doch irgendwas geben müssen muss
doch irgendwas markantes geben dann
würde ich sagen ganz ganz grob sehe ich
den wesentlichen unterschied zwischen
westlichen denkens und östlichen denken
in dem gegensatz von dynamisch und
statisch das östliche denken nicht mehr
so zum dynamischen als er sich dass die
dinge im fluss sind in der bewegung sind
veränderlich sind während das westliche
denken eher dazu neigt die dinge als
etwas statisches anzusehen was ich
erstmal nicht verändert was erstmal
wahrlich ist aber das ist dieser grobe
generalisierung und wahrscheinlich so
wie es gesagt aber falsch aber okay also
als einordnung ganz hilfreich vielleicht
das heißt aber also zu sagen wir können
auch in der westlichen antike
philosophen finden wahrscheinlich die
einen eine philosophie des flusses oder
also alles ist ein prozess in die
richtung so sagen so ansätze hatten
genauso wie wir in
östlichen systemen philosophen finden
könnten wahrscheinlich so das wäre ihr
ansatz oder ja ja ich denke schon also
wir finden die selbe vielfalt oder
zumindest eine vergleichbare vielfalt
biete sie aus der westlichen philosophie
kennen auch in der chinesischen
philosophie
also nehmen sie mal ganz am anfang der
griechischen philosophie parmenides da
so skerra kind alles ist im fluss
parmenides sagt alle veränderungen ist
nur illusion
das sind zwei absolute gegensätze die
überhaupt nicht miteinander vereinbar
sind und beide passen unter dieses große
dach der westlichen philosophie in china
sieht es nicht anders aus
ja und genau das was mir dazu sagen als
erster den sinn kam war auch das
berühmte jene und yang symbol das ja und
alles was damit einhergeht ich will
später nochmal genauer darauf eingehen
aber erstmal so der gedanke so ist da
vielleicht auch so in der logik dann
gibt es da vielleicht gibt es da
vielleicht auch noch irgendwie eine
feine unterschied weil wir haben hier
irgendwie gelernt dass sozusagen kein
video außen also aus einem gelernt aus
dem widerspruch kann alles entstehen
jede beliebige aussage also das heißt
wenn man eine aussage hat in einer
aussage nicht kann man alles behaupten
und das wollen wir nicht wir wollen ja
sozusagen konkrete wollen ja kenntnis
erlangen und konkrete erkenntnisse lange
so etwas spezielles hinauskommen nicht
beliebig sein und jetzt habe ich den
eindruck mit diesem jenen und jan kannst
was du dass man hat harmonie ist und es
gibt im gegensatz ist gibt es immer
gleichzeitig später gehen wir vielleicht
noch mal präziser und darauf ein oder
sie aber da habe ich den eindruck da ist
es auf einmal möglich dass ich so etwas
sage wie eine sache ist irgendwie weich
und nicht weich zugleich so ich habe das
gefühl es ist möglich oder es scheint
möglich zu sein dass man widersprüche
oder oder gegensätze von demselben
dingen gleichzeitig behaupten kann also
dass man gleichzeitig sagen kann aber
nicht
und dass meine frage ob sie was dazu
sagen können
was diese intuition betrifft also es
gibt natürlich in der chinesischen
philosophie solche strömungen oder
schulen die neigung zum mystischen haben
uns gerade im tourismus ist das schon so
dass man solche ideen finden kann wie
das dagegen setzte aufgehoben werden in
einer art dialektischen prinzip ich
würde das aber normalerweise oder
generalisierten form so weit fassen dass
man sagt die chinesische philosophie hat
ihre ganz eigenen logik oder das
chinesische denken baut auf einer
anderen logik auf als das westliche
denken wenn das so wäre dann könnten wir
es wahrscheinlich gar nicht verstehen
also ich bin schon der meinung es gibt
eine universelle logik und diese
universelle logik findet sich auch in
allen sprachen wieder und die sorgt
dafür dass auch unterschied hier
sprachen wechselseitige ineinander
übersetzbar und verstehbar sind also die
tatsache dass wir verstehen können was
die alten chinesen so gelehrt haben das
beweist quasi schon dass sie keine ganz
andere logik gehabt haben können es gibt
wie gesagt solche mystischen strömungen
die über das zusammenfallen der
gegensätze sprechen
oder es gibt dann auch im chinesischen
buddhismus ja solche schulen die sagen
dass es da eine realität gibt die
jenseits unserer begriffe steht oder
dass das nirvana die erleuchtung
weder seien noch nicht sein ist aber das
ist auch nichts was mit dem westlichen
denkens vollkommen fremd wäre
wir haben natürlich auch im westen
solche philosophen wie gerade aus einem
mystischen richtung kommen die genau
solche dinge behaupten also denken sie
an den nikolaus cusanus mit seiner
koinzidenz your pussy toren in
zusammenfallen der gegensätze also wir
kennen so was auch aus dem westen das
heißt auch hier zeigt sich wieder diese
vielfalt die man in china findet das
ganz fremde was angeblich in china so
auftaucht das können wir genauso gut bei
uns zuhause finden
danke ja dann lass uns doch gemeinsam
jetzt in
den da es muss schauen einfach als
konkretes beispiel zu dem ganzen thema
da wäre einfach als allererste frage
könnten sie so einführende einer
einfachen einführen so was ist da es
muss so was würde das beschreiben für
jemanden der das noch nie gehört hat
also der tourismus das ist eine wichtige
strömung der chinesischen philosophie
die geht zurück auf zwei bekannte
vielleicht nicht ganz real existierende
philosophen namens laute und leise ist
unglaublich bekannt auch im westen
vielleicht unter anderem schreibweisen
da wird manchmal auch ioc oder sowas
geschrieben das sind alte alternative
transkriptionen aber viele viele leute
kennen zumindest vom hörensagen die sind
laut und sein buch das dauerte ziegen
oder tätig ist eine andere umschrift ist
eines der ganz großen meisterwerke der
chinesischen literatur 1 der einer der
großen philosophischen texte der
menschheit und diese touristische
philosophie ist eine philosophie die
lehrt dass es innerhalb der natur oder
innerhalb des universums ein universales
prinzip gibt dass hinter allem steht die
touristische philosophie versteht die
realität als permanent im wandel
begriffen als permanent im fluss und
hinter diesen permanenten wandel der
verschiedenen dinge da steht das eine
dass das prinzip dieses wandels und das
ziel der touristischen philosophie
besteht darin dieses dow zu erkennen und
sich im menschlichen leben an dieses
dauer anzupassen das heißt den fluss zu
sehen und mit ihm zu schwimmen also sich
an den unaufhaltsam wandel des
universums anzupassen und auf diese art
und weise zu einem gelingenden leben zu
kommen zusammen genau also da ist muss
hat sozusagen seinen namen zur sprung
von diesem prinzip den universalen
prinzip und
das ist was genau kann man das greifen
so sie haben gesagt das ist das prinzip
der veränderung oder ganz genau her also
man kann es nicht wirklich in dem sinne
greifen die touristen sind sich da ganz
einig dass das nur auf eine intuitive
art und weise zu erkennen ist das ist
diese mystische richtung von der ja eben
gesprochen habe die teuersten sind eben
der meinung es gibt jenseits der
begrifflichkeit jenseits des rationalen
denkens noch ein anderes
erkenntnisvermögen dass wir haben dass
wir eben mit unseren begriffen als
intuition bezeichnen können also eine
art nun konzeptuelle erkenntnisfähigkeit
und wenn wir die gebrauchen also eine
art mystische versenkung in die natur
eintreten dann können wir dieses prinzip
des dow erfassen können wir das eine
prinzip erfassen das hinter aller
veränderungen in universum steht dh das
verständnis von erkenntnis ist da schon
anders als bei uns kommt darauf an was
man miteinander vergleicht also wenn man
jetzt natürlich so jemand nimmt wie
descartes oder kant oder lockt also die
großen klassiker der westlichen
erkenntnistheorie dann müsste man
natürlich sagen sicher das was die
pisten da lehrern das ist was anderes
das ist eine art von erkenntnis die in
diesen westlichen philosophie nicht
berücksichtigt ist aber auch da muss man
wieder sagen natürlich gibt es im westen
auch ideen davon wie eine erkenntnis
jenseits von begriffen möglich sein
könnte wie eine erkenntnis in seiner
mystischen erkenntnis weise denkbar sein
sollte also ja nehmen wir die neue
platonischer beispielsweise denken sind
leute wie platin oder die christlichen
abkömmlinge davon wie den pseudo
dionysius die sind selbstverständlich
auch der meinung dass dieser einheit das
eine dass das nur mit einer über
begrifflichen art und weise der
erkenntnis gefasst werden kann
neben keine anstalten das irgendwie
begrifflich zu fassen
diese neue platten haben sie dann
beispiel dafür sozusagen wie wie die wie
die also wo da die parallele ist einfach
also genau ein konkretes beispiel ein
konkretes beispiel naja also bei den
neuen platten könnte haben wir das eine
das eine das sozusagen auch das prinzip
ist was hinter allen einzeln dingen
steht was dann nur geschaut werden
diese schau ist eine rein geistige schau
die nicht durch begriffe vermittelt ist
das unterscheidet sich also davon wie
wir ganz normale dinge um uns herum
erkennen würden und das ist ganz ähnlich
dieser mystischen intuition die werden
doris muss haben auch da sagen die dauer
ist dass wir müssen die begriffe zurück
lassen wir müssen unsere konzepte von
gut und böse vom richtigen falsch auch
zurücktreten lassen und jenseits dieser
konzepte dann da können wir dann die
reine nicht konzeptuelle realität des
dow erfassen
ja dann so handelt sich beim dow ist
muss um philosophie war sie am kernel
wäre so aber es ist sodann zur
philosophie oder kann man es auch als
religion fassen wenn sie meinten
freundes hans dann zu mystischer aspekte
also gibt es dann unterschied sollte
dieses unterschiedlich auslegen und wenn
ja wie macht man ein unterschied fest
zwischen der dauer zwischen philosophie
und der touristischen religionen falls
denn sowas gibt ja das ist natürlich
jetzt eine frage die eigentlich nur von
jemandem aus dem westen gestellt werden
kann überhaupt also diese diese
kategorien religion und philosophie sind
dem klassischen chinesischen denken
eigentlich vollkommen fremd es gibt in
klassischen chinesisch kein begriff für
philosophie und es gibt keinen begriff
religion das moderne chinesisch kennt
ausdrücke für philosophie und religion
die sind aber interessanterweise erst im
19 jahrhundert geprägt worden und zwar
auf dem umweg über japan
das heißt die japaner suchten nach
irgendwelchen begriffen mit denen sie
diese restlichen ausdrücke philosophie
und religion wiedergeben konnten fanden
in der eigenen sprache nichts vor und
haben einfach neue begriffe dafür
geschaffen die dann in chinesische
übernommen worden sind
eben weil es überhaupt nichts gab womit
man diese westlichen konzepte ausdrücken
konnte das heißt wenn man sich jetzt
anguckt wie im chinesischen diese nennen
wir es mal philosophien bezeichnet
werden des daoismus des konfuzianismus
usw
dann gibt es da eine reihe von
verschiedenen ausdrücken die
unterschiedliche aspekte widerspiegeln
aber die alle nicht dem entsprechen was
wir mit religion oder philosophie meinen
also zum beispiel wird der tourismus
würde auf chinesisch zum beispiel heißen
sie heißt einfach leere
also die lehre vom das wäre eine
möglichkeit wie man das bezeichnungen
die lehre ist natürlich absolut waage
und könnte sowohl philosophie als auch
religion als auch was ganz anderes
heißen oder man spricht von dauert das
ist dann auch sowie die lehre oder das
lernen dass da etwas was man über das
dauerlärm kann oder man spricht von
dauer ca
das wäre dann die schule des dow es muss
also der dauer ismus als die schule oder
die gemeinschaft der dow ist ist das
eine philosophie ist dass eine religion
es ist nicht klar zu sagen wenn man
jetzt aber die westlichen begriffe nimmt
also wenn man jetzt sagt kann ich das
einpressen in mein schema von
philosophie oder religion muss man sagen
das kann beides sein
also man kann den dow ist muss als
philosophie betrachten man kann diese
texte von dranse von lauter als
philosophische texte betrachten und
lesen und man kann eine philosophie
daraus konstruieren
in dem sinne dass es sich hier um ein
theoretisches system handelt das
versucht auf eine bestimmte art und
weise die realität zu beschreiben
konsequenzen für das menschliche leben
abzuleiten aber aus diesem
philosophischen system oder diesem was
auch immer das gewesen ist hat sich im
lauf der chinesischen geschichte eine
ganz eigene religion entwickelt also es
gibt auch heute noch in china den dow es
muss als eine religion die sich auch mit
vielen volkstümlichen elementen
verbunden hat es gibt da es tische
klöster es gibt es tische priester und
mönche und bestimmte drastische rituale
kulte der götter verehrung und so weiter
und so fort das würden wir ganz klar als
religion bezeichnen aber es lässt sich
nicht einfach trennen von diesem
philosophischen dauer ist muss der ganz
am anfang gestanden hat
würden sie sagen dass die dieser
mystische aspekt auch ein praktischer
ist die man in sein lebensweltliche
seien irgendwie mit einbindet auf jeden
fall also der tourismus hat eine ganz
klar praktische ausrichten das ziel für
die dauer ist es immer gewesen
ja das gute leben also ein leben zu
führen das uns als menschen unserer
menschlichen natur angemessen ist und
dass uns auch wieder zurückführt in
diese einheit mit der natur aus der wir
ursprünglich rausgefallen sind also da
es muss es ganz klar eine
lebensphilosophie eine philosophie die
praktische implikationen hat also zum
beispiel zeigt sich dass in diesem
begriff des nichthandelns oder way
das sind relativ kompliziert der begriff
es heißt nämlich nicht dass man nichts
tun sollte also nicht untätigkeit oder
so etwas also die wörtliche übersetzung
ist nicht handeln genau ok wörtliche
übersetzung ist nicht handeln aber es
bedeutet eben nicht untätigkeit
tatenlosigkeit sondern es bedeutet
vielleicht besser übersetzt nicht
eingreifen
genau genau da haben wir wieder die sind
das prinzip der ständigen veränderung
die ja uns einfach bestimmt ganz genau
das universum verändert sich permanent
also das einzige was beständiges im
universum ist der wandel und wir als
menschen müssen lernen uns diesen wandel
anzupassen uns nicht dagegen zu stellen
nicht einzugreifen in diesen wandel des
universums das ist das way das
nichthandeln nichthandeln geschieht dann
wenn ich nicht darüber nachdenke was ich
tue wenn ich nicht reflektiere was ich
tue wenn ich ganz im einklang bin mit
meiner natur meiner tätigkeit mich
einfach von der tätigkeit mit nehmen
lasse treiben lasse also denken sie
vielleicht eine klavierspielerin die
ganz versunken ist in ihr spiel ein
kompliziertes stück spielt und nicht
drüber nach dem was sie tut
sie spielt einfach sie muss nicht drüber
nachdenken welche taste muss ich jetzt
greifen wie stark muss ich diese taste
anschlagen und was kommt jetzt als
nächstes man sie spielt einfach sie geht
ganz in dieser tätigkeit auf das wäre
ein beispiel für wiiware eben nicht
untätigkeit tut ja was sie spielt
klavier aber sie verschwindet selbst
komplett hinter dieser tätigkeit
ich finde es aber interessant dass bei
dem beispiel das sehr voraussetzung ist
dass man an den punkt kommt also ich
meine
diddy hat vielleicht jahrelang
jahrzehnte geübt dass sie an diesem
punkt kommt so ein kompliziertes stück
seinen gedankenlos zu spielen oder wer
ihr beispiel genauso wie mäßig unterwegs
wenn wir von einem klavierspieler
anfänger sprechen
der anfänger gerade nicht er muss schwer
darüber nachdenken was er da gerade tut
er muss ständig sein handeln
reflektieren muss ständig fragen was tue
ich gerade was muss ich als nächstes tun
die klavierspielerin die es
perfektioniert hat die nicht und
trotzdem sieht es bei ihr vollkommen
mühelos aus man sieht er ja nicht an was
alles dahinter steckt das heißt diese
praxis des way ist etwas was wir uns
erst als menschen an gewöhnen müssen was
wir erst lernen müssen wir sind
dummerweise durch unsere menschliche
kultur und zivilisation weggekommen von
dieser ursprünglichen einheit mit der
natur mit dem dauer und deswegen müssen
wir erst lernen wieder in dieses buch in
dieser einheit zurückzufinden
ich habe ein bild ist es von meinem qufu
training war alles machen dann kommt vom
meister sozusagen vorgezeichnet bekommen
gehabt wo so ein bisschen der ich weiß
nicht wie ich das beschreiben soll aber
dabei wurde das sozusagen diese die welt
wie sie sozusagen wie wir sie wahrnehmen
so ein bisschen aufgezeichnet als als
eine linie von oben nach unten und
angefangen hat es mit dem daum was sehr
abstrakt ist und ich finde nicht
greifbar
und dann ging es weiter mit diesem
dieser kinder erzählung das da wollte
sich selber sehen und hat deswegen ein
gegensatz zu schaffen und aus diesem
gegensatz kam dann das lean und yang
symbol und das kann man dann auch
irgendwie vier teilen und dann kommt man
auch vier eigenschaften dann auf 8 16 32
bis man bei den 10.000 dingen ist
irgendwie die so als 10.000 dinge habe
ich mitbekommen oder gelernt dass es
irgendwie das unendliche unendliche
kategorien der welt so und genau und und
und und ich weiß nicht ob es dafür namen
gibt für diese darstellung
und nicht wissen sie ob es dafür einen
namen gibt ja also dieses schema diese
schematische darstellungen wie alle
dinge stück für stück abgeleitet werden
aus dem einen das gibt es in
verschiedenen varianten immer wieder in
der chinesischen philosophie oder auch
in der touristischen philosophie also
ein
ein beispiel dafür wäre das klassische
sogenannte time to also dass tai chi
diagramm wenn sie so wollen von dunkle
schuhe das ist ein etwas späterer
philosoph der chinesischen antike da
haben wir diesen gedanken dass am anfang
das höchste eine steht dass heidi die
höchste einheit und aus dem heraus das
dauert dann moniert oder ausschließt
oder so etwas und sich dann immer weiter
aufspaltet zunächst in diesen gegensatz
von ihnen & young und diese beiden
polaren kräfte die einander
gegenüberstehen bringen dann durch ihren
gegensatz und durch den versuch sich
wechselseitig immer zu verdrängen alle
anderen dinge hervor immer dann erst in
der kombination das ihn und dass ihnen
das gang das young beziehungsweise ihn
und jungen zusammen sind wir bei 4
und wenn die dann miteinander zusammen
kommen kommt darauf achten wenn die dann
miteinander kombiniert werden kommen wir
auf die 64 kombinationen wie sie die
imagine finden können die dann sozusagen
die grundsituation des daseins
beschreiben können naja ok und und sie
hatten jetzt angesprochen dass unser
menschliches dasein natürlicherweise
sich immer mehr vom dach entfernt mit
der zeit wenn wir aufwachsen und das ist
ja eine gewisse art eine parallele zu
diesem schema man kann das ja sozusagen
einfach runter gehen am anfang als kind
und als baby hat man vielleicht noch
nicht die wahrnehmung der welt wo man so
sagt du das ist ein stuhl ein tisch ein
stift ich und du so manch man nimmt
einfach erstmal alles war und die älter
man wird desto mehr einteilungen macht
mann und das meer geht man sozusagen
dieses schema unter das meer teilt man
die welt ein
und genau und dann wahrscheinlich
interessant dass das für mich so eine
parallele zu sehen ist und und und und
und und jetzt ist sozusagen die frage
nach dem gelingenden leben oder nacht so
dass der sinn des lebens das ziel des
lebens
was ist es sowas ist
es ist unser ziel einfach wieder
zurückzukommen zum daraus dass
vielleicht das ziel beim dow es muss
tatsächlich ja also für die dollsten ist
wirklich das beste menschliche leben
oder die beste menschliche lebensform
die des kleinen kindes man findet das
sind da ist muss immer wieder dass das
kleine kind als das ideal der
menschlichkeit dargestellt das ist nicht
der erwachsenen nicht der kultivierte
gebildete mensch der seinen platz in der
gesellschaft gefunden hat
das kleine baby das den ganzen tag nur
brüllt und in die windel macht und
ansonsten sich wenn nichts weiter
interessiert als wie es seinen bauch
voll kriegen kann
das ist das ideal des tourismus warum
weil dieses kleine baby eben noch voll
drin ist in der einheit mit seiner
eigenen natur mit dem das hat noch nicht
gelernt sich zu entfernen
von dieser ursprünglichen einheit
deswegen ist alles was wir eigentlich so
als errungenschaften der zivilisation
betrachten würden also unsere kultur
unsere staatliche ordnung unserer
technologie das ist für die dauer ist
nur symptomen des verfalls ein zeichen
dafür dass wir uns in unserer
eigentlichen lebensform immer weit
entfernt haben deswegen kann es nur das
eine ziel geben
zurück zur natur also zurück zur einheit
mit dem dow in dem wir so eine art
regression einleiten also indem wir
immer weiter uns reduzieren uns immer
weiter zurückziehen uns immer weiter der
ursprünglichen natur annähern also
prinzip wieder raus aus der menschenwelt
kommen und rein in die natur gehen
das bedeutet dann für die dauer ist auch
so etwas wie einerseits technik
feindschaft zivilisations feindschaft
insgesamt aber auch so etwas wie ein lob
der dummheit also die intelligenz der
intellekt auch die philosophie sind
letzten endes nur verfallserscheinungen
die vernunft kommt nämlich erst dann zum
tragen wenn die einheit mit dem
ursprünglichen dauer verloren gegangen
ist deswegen ist für die dauer ist ein
oft gerade die dummheit und die
nutzlosigkeit das ziel das wir anstreben
sollten denn dann haben wir den weg zum
zurückgefunden
wenn ich jetzt versuche bei der dummheit
so ein bisschen dann trotzdem noch ein
wert hin zu sehen könnte man vielleicht
nicht so den unterschied zwischen
interpretationen und wahrnehmung treffen
das so zu sagen dass das
vorangeschrittene der verfall des da das
ist so die einteilung die trennung und
das das und kategorisieren und das
passiert ja wenn man interpretiert
kategorisiert man irgendwie und auf der
anderen seite steht sagen die dummheit
wie sie genannt haben aber auch
gleichzeitig das kind zum beispiel das
einfach nur wahrnimmt also die
wahrnehmung wäre das irgendwie
möglichkeiten der dummheit auch
irgendwie was gutes zu schreiben
ja natürlich also dummheit muss als was
gutes vereinen dummheit ist also es ist
nicht blöd sein oder etwas sondern es
ist den geist frei machen von nutzlosen
kategorien von nutzlosen begriffen das
was wir philosophen für das wichtigste
halten in die begriffsbildung und das
operieren mit begriffen um zu rationalen
erkenntnissen zu gelangen das ist für
die dauer ist nur unsinn unsinn der den
wahren blick auf die wirklichkeit
verstellt deswegen ist das lob der
dummheit vielleicht ein bisschen
polemisch formuliert man könnte auch
davon sprechen dass es ein lob der
gedankenlosigkeit ist oder ein lob des
unverstellten denkens aber dieses
unverstellte denken sieht natürlich für
den der gewohnt ist rational und
begrifflich zu denken wie dummheit aus
und was ich nicht gefragt habe wenn
jetzt so einer mit mystischem
interessantesten in davos muss
herantritt und vielleicht auf der suche
nach der erleuchtung ist wäre das dann
auch das ziel der erleuchtung wovon wir
gerade gesprochen haben zurück zum dazu
kommen oder ja also ja diese erleuchtung
besteht eigentlich in einem vollkommen
innerweltlichen zustand im zustand
wieder eins geworden zu sein mit dem dow
damit der ursprünglichen natur also es
ist keine art von transzendente
erleuchtung oder so etwas kein
überschreiten eine transzendente sphäre
sondern es ist einfach nur ein zustand
man könnte vielleicht sogar sagen ein
bewusstseins oder ein da seins zustand
in dem ich mich dann befinde und dieser
da sein zustand ist vollkommen in
erhältlich und ist das gelingende leben
was ja irgendwie um dahin zu kommen
müssen ja auch irgendwas tun und zwar so
möglichst wenig eingreifen
die veränderung der welt und das
erfordert viel übung oder oder viel zeit
und erfahrung und dass ich mich gefragt
habe genau dann landet man durch diese
durch dieses prinzip irgendwie wenn man
das schafft auszuüben oder eben genau
nicht auszuüben dass man da zu einem
gelingenden leben kommen kann was ich
mich jetzt gefragt habe ist haben die
ein bestimmtes konzept von glück und
genau haben also sehen die da also geht
es uns glücklich sein ist ein
gelingendes leben dadurch definiert dass
man glücklich ist oder oder haben sie
vielleicht an der fall eine ganz andere
definition davon genau was machen die
mit diesem glücks thema was ja auch in
unserer westlichen kultur total
inflationär benutzt wird die ganze zeit
und auch gar nicht so klar ist
eigentlich aber das hat mich auch
interessiert ja also man kann die dauer
ist muss schon beschreiben als eine art
hedonistische philosophie als als eine
philosophie die nach einem möglichst
guten angenehmen leben für uns streben
dieses gute und angenehme das wird schon
verstanden als ein in diesem leben
gelebt ist gutes angenehmes und zwar auf
mich als individuelle personenbezogenes
ein gutes leben also man kann das dann
gegenüber stellen dann wird es
vielleicht klarer mit den konfessionen
kommt sozialismus der lehrt das gute
leben für den menschen das findet in der
gesellschaft statt also in dem ich mich
in meiner gesellschaft einbringen indem
ich politisch aktiv bin in dem ich in
meine familie eingebunden bin ich meine
eltern meine kinder kümmere als in dem
ich meine rolle in der menschlichen
gesellschaft möglichst gut erfülle
da lebe ich ein gutes leben sagen die
konfusion die dauer ist hingegen sagen
vergessen wir das vergessen wir den
start
vergessen wir auch die familie ziehen
wir uns zurück auf das eigentliche leben
das leben als sagen wir mal biologische
wesen als naturwesen die wir eigentlich
sind wenn es uns in diesem sinne gut
geht dann haben wir ein gutes leben ja
irgendwie interessant da auch noch mal
den kontrast zu sehen zu irgendwie so
sagen diesen labels oder klischee
aussagen
im moment leben ist total wichtig zu
innerer ruhe und zum glück kommen so und
mein problem ist ja immer so was genau
wird damit gesagt was das heißt es denn
so und ja und deswegen habe ich mir
genau aus unserem gespräch erhofft dass
es ein bisschen präziser wird und
konkreter und ich habe den eindruck es
wurde ziemlich konkret und man kann aber
wir haben es geschafft sie haben es
geschafft dass dinge zu benennen und
deswegen danke auf jeden fall für diese
vielen aspekte ich denke so ja also
sonst habe ich keine fragen gerade mehr
für die übernahme ist muss aber trotzdem
noch zwei weitere fragen und zwar die
eine sache wäre sie haben beide fragen
zu implizit beantwortet aber trotzdem
ein lesetipp für jemanden der sich jetzt
mit dem dadaismus auseinandersetzen
möchte was sollte er lesen also am
besten ist es natürlich wenn man einfach
in die texte selber ein steigt also die
originaltexte sich anschaut das ganze
ist einer meiner persönlichen lieblings
text aus der chinesischen philosophie
also es ist sehr lebhaft geschrieben
sammlung von anekdoten von gesprächen
diskussionen oder auch von parabeln
mystische mythischen erzählungen
das liest sich also unglaublich gut man
kann es einfach aufschlagen anfangen zu
lesen das ist garantiert irgendwas gut
ist dabei was man findet also ich würde
jedem empfehlen der einfach mal lust hat
mehr da ist muss erfahren sich das buch
branche zu besorgen und einfach los zu
lesen das dauerte gegen ist ein ganz
anderer text das ist sehr obskur
geschrieben einer sehr dunklen schwer
verständlichen sprache ist es extrem
schwierig das gut zu übersetzen und
aufgrund seiner kürze wird es auch ja
sehr hermetisch wirken auch viele
leserinnen und leser die sich da ohne
anleitung als erstes dran waren trotzdem
würde ich sagen einfach mal versuchen
es ist komisch als ich das erste mal ich
weiß noch genau es als schüler
reingeguckt haben das dauerte ging habe
ich nach drei seiten das ding wieder weg
gelegt und gesagt was um alles in der
welt soll das denn sein weil ich nichts
verstanden habe
[Musik]
suchen was trotzdem also ich würde
empfehlen in die texte selber rein zu
schauen und wenn man auf der suche ist
nach unterstützung wenn man das gefühl
hat ich bräuchte jetzt jemand in dem wir
das gut erklären kann das band wieder ja
meine videos zum da ist muss ich
anschauen da vielleicht klappt das ja
auch ganz gut
oder wenn man eher auf lesen steht dann
empfehle ich sehr von einer rods und
über schleichert die einführung
klassische chinesische philosophie hat
mir auch dies schon etliche jahrzehnte
alt hat mir auch damals als student gute
dienste geleistet als es darum ging mich
in diesen texten zu arbeiten
ja ich denke wir verlängern das auch
noch in der beschreibung und die zweite
letzte allerletzte frage wäre was
studiert man für eine philosophie wenn
man in china studiert wie sie jetzt zb
habe ich dann chinesische texte
hauptsächlich oder lese ich auch kanton
aristoteles also das philosophiestudium
in china das ist anders aufgebaut als
hier im westen also ein typische
philosophie abteilung an der
chinesischen universität sieht so aus
dass es drei säulen gibt sozusagen also
einmal natürlich chinesische philosophie
dann als zweites marxistische
philosophie das bringt nun eben das
system der sozialistischen volksrepublik
china mit sich und als drittes dann
westliche philosophie und daneben gibt
es oft noch so kleinere department für
ästhetik ethik logik und so weiter und
so fort
also das philosophiestudium in china
selber ist durchaus breit aufgestellt
studierende der philosophie in china
lernen sehr viel auch über westliche
philosophie und kennen sich
normalerweise auch ganz gut
also durchaus vergleichbar mit
studierenden im westen mit den
klassikern der westlichen philosophie
aus also auch die haben ihren kant und
ihren weg hat und so weiter gelesen
darüber hinaus wird daneben aber auch
deutlich mehr als bei uns ist ja klar
chinesische philosophie gemacht also in
der hinsicht muss ich wirklich sagen ist
die akademische philosophie in china
deutlich weiter und deutlich
diversifizierter und internationaler als
an vielen départements bei uns in der
westlichen welt noch der fall ja dann
hoffe ich dass wir da auch mal hinkommen
bedanke mich für das interview
und falls ihr interesse an mehr solche
videos habt einfach schreibt es in die
kommentare leichtes abonniert und bis zu
einem nächsten mal
ciao